le petit village de cintegabelle n'a pas
beaucoup changé depuis cannes à golubev
ya grandi dans les années 70 a hérité de
la datcha de son père et vient tous les
étés avec son mari et sa petite fille
elle est retraitée lui est un
photographe à 60 ans et non majine par
leur vie ailleurs
même si l'occasion qui te la russie
s'est présenté plus d'une semaine
il incarne une génération aux valeurs
traditionnelles et voteront oui au
référendum mercredi oui pour que la foi
en dieu soit enchâssée dans la
constitution comme valeur fondamentale
oui pour exclure les homosexuels du
mariage pour de bon et oui surtout pour
que de la dîmière poutine puisse rester
au pouvoir ad vitam aeternam silver mist
si vous voulez vous et en vertu de la
constitution révisé les mandats passés
de vladimir poutine seront remis à zéro
pour qu'ils puissent en solliciter deux
autres c'est un référendum qui n'en est
pas vraiment un puisque les changements
ont déjà été entérinés
reste que pour légitimer l'exercice et
s'assurer que les partisans du oui à y
voter
l'état va jusqu'à leur promettre des
cadeaux des voitures et même des
appartements
piscine s'affiche désormais comme le
père conservateur de la nation
le bouclier contre toute influence
néfaste de l'étranger du commentateur
sergueï markov approche dite rennais
présidence
same time mais vu notre bateau
comment une seule capable de défendre la
russie contre la guerre hybride que lui
livre l'occident dit markov dans une
entrevue télévisée la semaine dernière
poutine a même expliqué qu'il lui faut
cette option de rester au pouvoir car
désigner son successeur serait une
menace à la stabilité de la russie
puissante qu'il a rien vente à saint
pétersbourg le soleil de minuit des
célèbres nuits blanches offre un des
spectacles les plus attendus de l'année
les jeunes surtout ne mordent pas ce
qu'ils considèrent la propagande de
l'état
qu'est ce qu'un tube et
ce sont leurs enfants qui devront vivre
avec les conséquences des changements à
la constitution
une russie de plus en plus isolé du
reste du monde dit le restaurateur
alexander qui a dû terminent 2es
restaurant pour de bon à condition qu'on
recule à une vitesse allant vers les
années les plus grise de l'union
soviétique dit-il il nous faut du sang
chaud mais pour ramon c'est le contraire
il parle de vladimir poutine comme un
dieu qui a sorti du pétrin économique et
de l'humiliation pour ce métier et me
till de protester des romanes de toute
façon il n'y a personne d'autre à
l'horizon pour le remplacer à 110 par
poutine est une institution et lille à
dire que saint pétersbourg et son
mythique pont levant ont toujours été
symbole de la modernisation et
d'ouverture de la russie sur l'occident
lien cette veille d'un référendum
historique l'europe pousse pas si proche
n'a jamais paru aussi l'eau
et tamara étonnamment ce soir le canada
s'est invité dans ce référendum en
russie un message publié par
l'ambassadrice canadienne à moscou en
soutien à la communauté lgbt sem
l'indignation
oui et certains ont réussi par même des
gérances politique de la part du canada
madame aline leclerc est ambassadrice à
moscou depuis seulement quelques mois
l'a publiée samedi sur sa page facebook
personnelle le message en anglais mais
sous titré en russe qu'elle adresse à la
communauté lgbt de réussir qui elle
offre son soutien et à l'écrit que la
situation est particulièrement difficile
pour cette communauté en russie elle
parle d'une augmentation de la violence
et de l'intimidation de la part même des
autorités légales mais le plus loin elle
ajoute qu'elle craint que les
changements constitutionnels s'ils sont
adoptés à la suite de ce référendum
risque de restreindre encore plus les
droits de la communauté lgbt en russie
donc c'est un message qui ne pas passer
du tout aujourd'hui sur les grandes
chaînes de télévision russes sont
écoutés vraiment par des millions et des
millions de russes surtout en en cette
période de référendum la vidéo d'abord
tourné en boucle c'est est suivi de
commentaires de gens très près du
kremlin entre autres des députés du
parti russie unie de vladimir poutine
qui disait mais de quel droit elle se
mêle de ce dossier là c'est de
l'ingérence politique ils vont même
jusqu'à demander est ce qu'elles soient
rappelés et réprimandé donc c'est vrai
qu'elle va plus loin que d'autres
ambassadeurs qui en cette semaine de la
fierté gay ont profité de l'occasion
pour offrir leur soutien aux communautés
lgbt de plusieurs pays
il n'y a pas de crise diplomatique je
vous dirai pour l'instant entre le
canada et la russie
mais disons que c'est une façon assez
abrupte de commencer son mandat en
russie alors que les relations entre le
canada et le pays de vladimir poutine
sont encore très très bien à suivre donc
merci beaucoup tamara au revoir